another concern that I have about the
incoming Donald administration is
related to vaccines because as if Trump
wasn't already slated to have a hugely
anti-science administration we've got
the entire climate science denial is our
official position thing that rents
Priebus said on Fox News Sunday over the
weekend Donald Trump is accused of
assuring anti-vaccine activists that he
is going to advance their cause when he
is president of the United States so
first the background remember that
Donald has a long history of vaccine
misinformation it started when he
expressed his beliefs that there might
be a relationship between vaccines and
autism that was nearly a decade ago it
had already been discredited at that
point and even after that he continued
to repeat those ideas and he never found
it necessary to correct or refine those
positions during the election in comes
Jennifer Larson the CEO of the autism
focused Holland Center in which she
explained that she and other
vaccinations skeptics as they call
themselves discussed her concerns and
their concerns with Trump at a donor
event in August and according to her
account Trump assured her he is on their
side here is a quote from this blog post
uh at the by the CEO of the Holland
Center now that Trump one we can all
feel safe in sharing that mr. Trump met
with autism advocates in August he gave
us 45 minutes he was extremely educated
on our issues mark stated you can't make
America great with all these sick
children and more coming Trump shook his
head and agreed he heard my son's
vaccine injury story and he told them
about Thompson and gave him vast dr.
Gary ended the meeting by saying Donald
you were the only one who can fix this
he said I will we left hopeful lots of
work left to do now the reference to
backs there is of course the documentary
film involving disgraced dr. Andrew
wakefield he happened to have been in
the room during this meeting he uh
authored that famous and now widely
debunked study claiming that there's a
connection between the MMR vaccine and
autism we later of course found out that
number one the study was just completely
bogus and number two that Andrew
Wakefield had a financial conflict of
interest he was out there saying and I
don't know if you know about this Pat we
follow this pretty closely this guy
Andrew Wakefield he went out and said
the MMR vaccine is connected to autism
and then it turned out he was involved
financially with a company that made a
measles only vaccine so if he
successfully convinced you that the MMR
vaccine is bad then you could say well I
at least want to vaccinate against
measles oh hey there's this company
offering the measles only vaccine and it
just so happens that Andrew Wakefield
was involved with them this guy is real
scum and he's been widely debunked and
discredited he was in the room when this
supposedly took place and it's not only
in the anti-vaccination community where
we see conflicts of interest even people
who deny climate change or the fact that
it's man-made will often have ties to
some fossil fuel corporations to yet
we've seen that and it's it's very
similar it like climate science denial
and anti-vaxxers there's similarities in
many ways and the conflicts of interest
that sometimes exist are definitely one
of those now whether this happened or
not you know this was a donor event uh
that some of these anti-vaxxers said
that they had a 45-minute meeting with
Trump did they or was this a meeting
that was part of a 45-minute rally it's
not really clear maybe Trump just told
everybody in the room I will advance all
of your causes we don't really know but
again this doesn't run counter to what
we heard Trump say during the primary
debates this doesn't run counter to the
constant anti-science comments on this
issue by Trump and it doesn't run
counter to the anti-science perspective
that Trump is adopting with regard to
many of the people that are going to be
part of his administration is there a
silver lining here yes and I have a
feeling that's a phrase I'm going to be
using pretty often during the Donald
administration is there a silver lining
here do we have any silver lining the
silver lining is that vaccine
regulations are mostly determined that
this
state-level like we've talked about
California's recent requirement that
there are no more uh uh sort of
religious and personal exceptions
granted for vaccinations if you're gonna
send kit the public school that's a
state-level decision mostly these rules
are determined at the state level but
from could still appoint vaccine
skeptics to important positions in the
CDC in the NIH in the FDA and we know
that his appointments on Climate run
totally counter to science so why
wouldn't those related to health and
medicine also run completely countered
science this is very scary stuff and
this is going to be 2017 under President
Donald brace yourselves